Let's [laughter]
go. Let's go. Do you think that they're aware of like how much
the insurgent left like actually hates them? I don't know if
they are. I don't know if like these Obama Democrats are like
tankies. When John Favreau is really mad that billionaires aren't
donating to the party, I think he's kind of like a tankie when
it when you think about it. That's like really tankie-coded.
>> I do want to start here cuz we're going to talk through
the DNC autopsy, some of the motivations for doing the DNC autopsy.
All right, we're going to look through all of it. Let's get into
it. You're making it easier for this group of people that you've
rightly identified to make hay and to like throw rocks at Democratic
Party in an unjustified or I guess in this context justified
manner, but for the wrong reason. Um I'll give Hutch a chance
if he wants to weigh in. If not, I can respond. It was the most
predictable Streisand effect ever, and I'm glad that the people
that are in the leadership position within the party itself are
not super online, but they need to hire people that are. Like
they need to hire a team of like three or four zoomers that are
super online because I could have predicted that this was going
to turn into a like they're going to make it about Gaza. It was
like really really really predictable. And um And so I don't
know if this means that he should resign at church. Who made
it about Gaza? Like I see that some people online made it about
Gaza, but who out of the actors that actually talked to Ken Martin
or actually dealt with Ken Martin were making it about
I understand that there were people on Twitter who might have
done that, okay? Not that I've seen them. I assume Hutch has
seen them cuz that's what he's totally obsessed with. That's
what he can't stop talking about. But
but but but but but but but but
Who Who that matters is talking about Gaza at all? Who cares?
>> seems like that's being teed up, um which is a little
depressing cuz I feel like people would just kind of more sinister
agendas are behind that because it seems like the Democratic
Party currently is doing a really good job of winning elections.
And so, you know, I don't know enough about his um performance
as DNC chair. I don't really know. >> Oh, Emma Vigeland?
Okay, I I I don't watch The Majority Report because I
I don't like Emma Vigeland's like takes on things, basically.
So, I'm not sure. >> Logistically, like if he's doing a
good job, but you know, I'm hesitant to call for resignations
every single time that particular mob gets pissed. But, also
to Pisco's point, yeah, I mean, this was like, I think a big
and it was kind of predictable. Um, I think they need people
that are more plugged in into the online space. There does seem
to be a disconnect and we need some people that can translate
internet for the >> So, Hutch is talking about the fact
that the fact of not actually releasing the DNC the autopsy,
but also I'm assuming at some point they're going to talk about
the fact that it was done totally
>> Do you think the people at the top, the the people in
the leadership, do you think that they're aware of like how the
insurgent left like actually hates >> I don't know if they
are. I I think they do. They just uh, probably discount it heavily.
Like, well, there's people making noise and those people, I believe
80 to 90% of them end up voting for Democrats in the end, so
they don't really see a need to try to win them >> Well,
like the McMurrow interview, um, for example.
>> Did you guys all watch that interview with, um, Matt
and Emma? >> It was not as like >> You know, you
know his name now, right? How do you not just call him the gay
>> Matt [laughter] Bernstein I think his name is. Matt
Bernstein and Emma Vigeland. Um, the tone wasn't super aggressive,
but the subtext was. Like, they were definitely kind of dripping
with contempt. And I just like in that kind of spot, I wonder
if McMurrow understood that she was walking into an interview
with, you know, two people who probably like think that she supports
genocide and whatever else thing they're going with. Um, same
same with Slotkin. I'm not sure if she was aware of the venue
that she was walking into.
>> Why would you be unaware? Why is that Why is that not
on the candidate themselves to be like aware of the positions
the people they're interviewing with have and then to pick their
interviews? If they think they're going to get like a really
unfavorable interview, you wouldn't just go into
like you wouldn't just go into any interview with having no idea
of who you're talking to. That you you hire like a comms director
for this entire >> Breaking Points and, you know, it's
not to say they should never do these kinds of interviews, but
uh, maybe we're stretching the point, but what I think there's
something there, but I I want to reject the framing that this
is about the insurgent left or the populist left versus the insider
left or the more normal left because the people who are frustrated
with Ken Martin the most are
>> Hahaha. [laughter] >> Oh no, Pisco. Pisco, don't
take my position precisely. I Pisco, you can't do it. Pisco,
don't do it. Pisco, no. Pisco, no. No. No. Pisco, no. >> fabulous
left versus the insider left or the more normal left because
the people who are frustrated with Ken Martin the most are people
who are like state chairs and are people who are inside the DNC
and are people who I don't think can be classified as like hater
of of Dems. These are the Politico people. These are um you know,
New York Times type people. So, I I don't really think that the
criticisms of Ken Martin can all be dealt with >> Uh these
people are the DNC isn't failing because they don't have the
right middle management. They're failing because they don't have
any charisma.
Geez, I agree on the charisma part. It's their top-level management
is taking a different strategy and people are very, very, very
concerned about how it's going to go. Combine that with the lack
of of hm what would the word be? Diligence on the autopsy and
not releasing it and not admitting what happened with it. When
you put these things together, the donors are very worried that
all of their money will be mismanaged. So, instead of donating
to the DNC, they're donating to a lot of campaigns specifically.
So, the DNC's actually spending all of its money very early on
just supporting state parties and like like state DNC parties,
right? Like at the Uh I mean that's that should be obvious what
I mean, right? Instead of what they usually do is they'll usually
raise money and then they'll put that money towards ads in specific
districts that are competitive.
Now, they're just giving out the money to the state DNC parties
even in blue states, right? Just to help them build up some kind
of machine. That's where that's what this guy wants to do and
so people are very, very concerned that one, they're not raising
very much money cuz the donors are scared and two, this guy's
spending all of their money so they have no war chest going into
the midterms. The DNC is like basically at net neutral. They're
they're basically at like zero dollars. They're not really going
to be able to spend in specific areas where they think they can
push for a a win.
Now, I don't think the overall Democrat machine is fundraising
that much less,
right? It's just that the DNC is not raising anything. The overall
Democratic Party, when you take into account the candidates,
the DCCC, the There's one other one. When you take all this into
account together, I think they're raising close to the same amount
of money they usually do,
but it's all going to different places. So, it will depend on
is the DNC fine dropping back and letting people run their own
campaigns and spending on their own? Like that really relies
on the donors to spend in the right places, whereas opposed to
recent or sorry, in the recent past, what's happened is they
give the money to the DNC and the DNC will spend it as appropriate,
like as as the Democratic Party sees it fit, right? Now the donors
are basically deciding where the money goes instead of giving
it to a a middleman, which is the DNC.
But there's the the DCCC as well. There's a couple other ones
that do this as well. So, like realistically, Ken Martin's strategy
might actually be
like the way he's doing it. Yes, DSCC, yes, and the DCCC, yes,
yes, yes. So, Ken Martin's strategy might actually be
it's just like the DNC would be taking on a different role, a
less like hands-on the wheel role, which might be good cuz they
kind of
to be honest with you. Like that's that's certainly an argument
he could make. Like we actually suck, so don't give your money
to us or give enough money to us so we can fund the state parties
and they can like build out infrastructure, hire people, and
get stuff done, like do door knocking and stuff, and basically
make it so it's easier to sign up and be a member of the Democratic
Party.
That could be okay. That could be an okay strategy, right? But
it is kind of going, "Yeah, we suck. Don't give a bunch of money
to us. Don't trust us to decide where that money should go. Just
donate where you want to donate." That's
I don't know, in a world where billionaires have like access
to insane statistics and stuff, that might actually be better
that these people could just run their own operation and fundraise
and and donate as they see fit. Possible.
Anyway, I I don't know that it actually
You know what I mean? I I really don't. I don't know if it actually
matters.
It It might be that the DNC not fundraising that much is not
that big a deal and Ken Martin is kind of on course. It's just
when you put together the lack of fundraising with spending a
bunch of their money, having a war chest, with the failed audit
that the the previous election audit, right? That Ken Martin's
done a couple things in concert that make people really squirrely
right now. And so a lot of people are calling for his resignation
all into um awareness about how bad faith some lefties are. >> No,
that's right. But But the initial major grievance, I would say,
was driven by the insurgent left with the Gaza narrative. And
I would I would say the Pod Save guys are aligned with them,
but >> That's not true. No, neither of those things is
are true. You're like a total
Neither of those things are true. Jon Favreau has been banging
on about an autopsy since the election ended, basically. I think
since December of
Basically, there's like this war between the the Obama-aligned
people and the Biden-aligned people. And that's another sub That's
like a sub plot line of this entire thing is basically, a lot
of the Obama guys think that the DNC has been run totally incompetently
since they've left, since they've been out of office, and they
don't want any of the people who are there and running it to
be running it anymore. Like, they want to step back in and take
it over again. Well, the funny thing is is they're doing a very
the Obama Democrats, like the more corporate-aligned Democrats,
Cenk Uygur's demons, OKAY? >> CORPORATE DEMS!
>> Cenk Uygur's demons, as some might call them, they are
trying, and I think succeeding, obviously, from the totally like
knuckle-dragging response,
they're succeeding in co-opting the leftist movement. They're
They're actually succeeding in this. Right? They're trying to
co-opt that movement. They're trying to, you know, Obama goes
and does a photo op with Mondaire Jones. Jon Favreau pushing,
talking to does a really favorable interview with Hasan
Right? All this stuff, they're trying to co-opt that movement
and bring it in and use that energy to get candidates elected.
They're still corporate dems. They still very much like are at
their heart aligned with and in service of corporate interests.
But they're trying to bring that other element in to give themselves
like a veneer of credibility.
Right? And it's so funny that it's working and the exact people
who should probably be against that, who don't want the leftists
in, are helping them do it. Right? When you attack Jon Favreau
for his interview on Hasan [__] you're helping him
incorporate Hasan [__] into the party. You don't
even understand that you're working against the thing you're
trying to stop. Because you are a low IQ, low impulse control,
zero empathy degenerate. We'll go back to this. >> You're
right. The state party The state level Democrats have have [laughter]
>> The Obama types? >> Yeah, yeah, definitely at
this point. I'm not saying they're like tankies or whatever,
but I think that they my >> what I was just I don't know
if like these Obama Democrats are like tankies. When Jon Favreau
is really mad that billionaires aren't donating to the party,
I think he's kind of like a tankie when it when you think about
it. That's like really tankie coded. Right? When you're when
you're upset that billionaires won't give your country party
like million dollar checks, that's like super tankie coded, I
think. >> of the Democratic Party, Hodge. >> That's
most of the Democrats. People who think that that that Gaza um
is a genocide or the Israelis committed a >> No, I mean
specifically the charge that they were withholding this report.
>> Because it said that Gaza lost her the >> I don't
think that the Pod Save America people said that. I heard them
come out after the um Jon Favreau interview and say that it was
because it was shoddy work This is before it leaked, before it
>> Yes. Yes.
They were saying we think it's been done poorly. We we don't
trust it. It's incompetence. Who also said Who said that before
they'd even made a statement? Uh that's me. What What that's
me. That's That was me. That was me. I said they're they're pissed
cuz they think the Biden staffers are incompetent. They think
anybody involved with the Biden campaign was totally incompetent.
Anybody who swept for the Biden campaign so Biden could run again
is totally incompetent and needs to be needs to metaphorically
in a political sense have their head cut off." That's what Jon
Favreau thinks, right? And that's what he's been doing. That's
how he's been operating since the last election. But, it unfortunately
Hutch just can't understand this. Hutch because well, it's bad.
That's why Hutch can't understand it, okay? Hutch hates Hasan.
Jon Favreau was nice to Hasan. Anyone who's nice to Hasan is
a tankie,
>> Oh, yeah, yeah. >> They had sources. They had
sources. >> So, I don't think they're promoting that narrative
in have anything, right? Like, this would have died down mostly
if Ken Martin had just never done that interview. I think that
that's probably what had happened. >> I I agree and I think
he screwed that up royally, but I I just the the arguments for
why he needs to go and and is failing are so weird to me. It's
like, well, the DNC doesn't have money, but we're spending it
and we're winning handily. So, it's like they're >> Unfortunately,
I'm probably going to agree well, hold on that last part. I don't
think you winning has anything to do with the DNC spending the
money right now. They're spending the money to build out the
local parties, the the local party offices, and stuff like this.
That's what they're spending the money for, right?
Realistically, they're spreading the money around in a way that
like it could be good in some way,
but there it's not leading to them winning. They're doing that
as a part of a deeper strategy, a long-term strategy, which I
like. I actually like that.
you cannot think that the spending of the money in the local
parties is what's doing it. Dude, they're spending money in every
state. That's not helping win special elections, idiot. How in
the world could you say that throwing $500 or $5,000 to every
state party every month, I think it's 5,000, to every state party
every month, how in the world could you possibly argue that that's
helping you win special elections? Spraying the money evenly
instead of spending on those special elections. That's not what
the money is doing. B
B so for real right now, man. Come on. They're concerned about
an election two elections from now and >> to use the bathroom
real quick. >> That you can't think like that. Like if
the guy's doing well right now, you got to work within the moment.
I think it's a crisis of credibility. >> Oh, sorry. What's
the metric, right? Is he still funding well fundraising well?
I don't remember. I know right after the election, obviously
fundraising was not where it needs to be, but people were waiting
for the DNC to come out with a here's how we're going to win
message. They're waiting to see how these elections go, how the
midterms go. And once those go and they're like, oh, the DNC
is spending the money well, that's when the money starts to roll
in. But like these kind of swings just like the, you know, approval
for the party that lost, like they're they they normally happen.
So, is there like a data that says they're raising on par with
2020? Um that I'm not sure off the top of my >> Well, I
think his explanation was that the donors are donat- donating
directly to the candidates. Um I don't know if that was just
cope, but like for example in 2016, if you're looking for historical
precedent, the DNC was literally bankrupt. They were I think
over $10 million in debt and Hillary bailed them out with her
war chest. So, I don't really know what like the normal kind
of baseline for have funds in the tank is for this moment in
time. >> Um that's
Does Hutch not realize that the DNC being bankrupt after a extremely
consequential presidential election makes total sense? Like that's
not a
That's not the same problem you're dealing with now. That's after
the election. If they've overspent, if they borrowed to to sell
out to try to win the election, that makes some sense. What doesn't
make any sense is going into a midterm before you've even hit
the part the midterm season where you would be spending on ads,
you're bankrupt. You you got nothing. Right? That's what's actually
concerning. That's really concerning.
He just made a totally like that point doesn't even remotely
come close to talking about the problems the DNC might have.
That's like a fundamentally uninformed and stupid opinion. Well,
actually after a presidential election, the DNC was bankrupt.
Okay, before a consequential midterm, the DNC is functionally
bankrupt. That's really bad. Hutch, that's really bad. Although,
actually I haven't checked their fund or anything in like a 2
months or something. They might be back in doing okay. I'm not
totally sure. But, in any case, from Hutch, that point he just
made doesn't even remotely answer the question of whether Ken
Martin's doing a good job. He just talked about some stuff. He
just said some that actually doesn't tie into the issue at hand
in any meaningful
>> Well, I think if you Well, just real quickly, if you
go toe-to-toe the RNC DNC or the DCCC versus the Republicans'
version, the Republicans are out-raising us tremendously with
these organizations. But, when you look at the individual candidates
like James Talarico versus Ken Paxton or John Cornyn, it's night
and day. We're completely annihilating
>> I just want to say though, with with the fact of the
DNC, I almost think, you know, whether or not anyone has any
specific expertise on the fundraising numbers and the individual
races versus the other committees, etc., there's a crisis of
confidence that I think needs to be assessed. And that is the
DNC's most important job is preparing for the presidential election,
the debates, that setting up the rules, the schedule, that kind
of stuff. And that is where things get very hairy and where I
think they need to have the most credibility. You see the kind
of problems you saw might say scandal that's happened in the
past where it has caused us issues. Now that we're facing a decade
past, how many people point to the Donna Brazil emails of 2016,
etc.
>> I mean, I really think this autopsy is enough of an
issue on its own. Like, the fact that you've been selling this
autopsy, "Hey, we're going to do a big autopsy. We're going to
release it." And then it turns out to be some AI-generated total
trash bucket. Like, that that does not inspire confidence at
all. >> is an area where I think you need to overcompensate
in terms of being upfront and being transparent, and that's crucially
what this episode, um, you know, shows a lack of.
winning has a way of smoothing over all the problems. So, I think
if we have a stellar midterms, you're going to see a lot less
complaints about Ken Martin. So, I think he deserves a chance
to get us through the midterms. And if we do have a bad midterms
or not as good of a midterms, and people can point to some problems,
we can. Then, we've got a 2-year runway to the elections, and
I think it's time to talk about perhaps stepping down. But right
now, that was a big point in my video is we're less than 6 months
from the midterms. This would be crazy to swap out our coach
right >> Isn't this kind of playing into the narrative
we were talking about last week and a lot of weeks, which is
you're comparing individual candidates who might stand on certain
policies that invigorate voters, and you're comparing this to
the DNC, which is supposed to be this generic apparatus that
then transfers those funds into a lot of elections, and you know,
raises money for this local one and this local one. If he's unable
to do that, like I think that's what you're measuring him on.
If we do well in the midterms, that could be completely absent
of DNC fundraising. I'm not saying it it is, but that has no
indication as whether or not he did a good job. That just means
those candidates, who according to him are the ones getting the
money and not the DNC, are doing a good job with their messaging
and their campaigns. So, I think you have to be able to look
at what did you actually do with the money, and did that actually
pan out, or did you not really have a big effect, right? >> I
I I agree. Another thing that >> I would ask IRI why he
thinks the D- the DNC has done a good job in any way. Like what
about the DNC and how it's run has led to wins in these elections?
>> that I didn't include in my video that people aren't
talking about is Trump is fundraising off of bribes. I mean,
he is asking for money for his ballroom and all sorts of thing.
Like it's a piggy bank for graft. So, to compare the DNC to that
is a little uh unfair, I think, too.
>> Was Was somebody comparing the DNC to >> I agree
with that. Like obviously a lot of the deck is stacked against
Democrats versus Republicans. But I think that there needs to
be some failure state that we recognize. What it would it take
for us to be like, "Okay, Ken Martin needs to go." What are the
metrics? And it's the similar kind of question. I'm not going
to demand you guys answer it now, uh that I often demand of pods.
Like what would it take for you to say that Schumer's doing a
bad job? Now, Hutch is already >> Linked to another short
13-ish minute discussion on the autopsy and who might replace
Ken Martin in the content links. Probably not as good as content
as this, but maybe a good watch in people's own time. Okay. All
right. We'll check it >> I'm not trying to mischaracterize
him or anything, but like this is what I'm talking about that
sometimes Democratic success is in spite of either incompetence
or just kind of genericness or not particularly superbness on
behalf of some of these institutional figures. That we're winning
in spite of them as opposed to because of them. >> So is
your is your position that you do want him to to resign? >> I'm
leaning towards he should go and just let's let's get someone
new and fresh. I don't I haven't called for it because to be
honest, I'm not like super read in on the the numbers aspect
in the fundraising. I think anyone who's calling for the NC chair
to step down should be aware of the relationship to donors. Um
but I am leaning in that direction because of how horrible this
event has shown him to be from a character perspective, from
a confidence perspective, from a personnel perspective. This
episode has shown bad judgment. And so that's why I'm leaning
in that direction. >> It just feels like
I I understand like you need confidence in the leadership and
sometimes it's not even really about the performance. Sometimes
the perception is the only thing that matters. Um I I guess this
feels like such
like a a footnote in terms of what his day-to-day probably looks
like for the >> Truth is I don't really know what his daily
operational sort of like jobs are and and but this feels like
it would just be on the low end of
>> But isn't that defeated by the idea that Jon Favreau
is like a DNC insider and he's saying that
he's saying that donors are scared to donate because they think
this this party is totally incompetent.
That's what's going on here, Hodge. Donors are scared to donate
because they think the party's totally incompetent. So it has
to be a massive part of his day-to-day. He has to be trying to
fix these relationships. What the [__] do you mean?
This can't be a big deal to him. This can't be a part of his
day-to-day. What? >> Orton, it does sound like he made
a bad decision, but >> Yeah, and then you say you don't
know how his day-to-day goes, but you're willing to undercut
what Jon Favreau is saying, what he's telling you. I believe
this being echoed by a lot of people, too. Matt Yglesias wrote
a whole piece on how much Ken Martin is up fundraising. >> It
it wouldn't be enough for me to say that he should step aside.
Now like if if you show me data that shows like, you know, a
lot of the state level Democrats are just don't have confidence
in him, then I would support calling for him to step aside, but
I just don't know what >> What did you guys think about
the whole like outing David Hogg thing that happened way at the
beginning of last >> What happened?
>> Ken Martin and and that kind of ill like they pushed
out David Hogg uh from the DNC. >> I I thought he was pushed
out because of there was some kind of a process issue. I I don't
know. >> that was that was it was there was some oh, you
need to hire a woman >> I don't know about this. >> I
never heard of this. Like, "Well, you weren't a woman, but really
it was because David Hogg was challenging more center like left
Democrats with like, "Hey, we need to replace these people who
are people who are actually going to get the job done." Very
like you maybe you want to call it insurgent left kind of like
tactics to say like let's get more progressive lefties in here.
But >> That's that's pretty >> The process thing
was just an excuse. >> Well, that's a pretty pretty serious
conflict. Like if you're going to join the DNC, then you should
you should be on the team. And I'm not saying, you know, this
is a democracy, so you can branch off and and do your own group
and try to support primary challengers. My understanding is that
he hasn't really been that successful so far, but I don't think
you can do both of those jobs at the same time. I do think it's
reasonable to ask that you just do one or the other.
>> Yeah, I I it was some procedural thing. They claimed
the vote didn't go the way it was supposed to and there was like
supposed to be another woman. It was a very soy cringe thing
that happened. Um I disagree with you so >> Hogg got ousted
of the DNC for wanting to primary centrists. Oh, interesting.
I didn't know that. That's kind of funny.
Mhm,
that changes my estimation of Ken Martin a little bit. >> Wait,
people did >> to push him out. To this day, I don't understand
why they couldn't work it out with him, but I disagree with you
that he was pushed out. I don't know, maybe I'm crazy. >> It
didn't work out because he formed a group who were [clears throat]
doing primary challenges and it's been DNC policy for years now
to support incumbents. And so, that is a pretty intense conflict
to have, you know? I don't know. You know, >> Should it
be DNC policy to support incumbents? I mean I mean maybe that's
one of the this is maybe different than the DNC leadership under
Ken Martin.
>> So, this is going to be a very interesting conversation
because it's about supporting the status quo. If everybody's
annoyed with the status quo, if everybody's frustrated with the
status quo, you're thinking about how you can inject some populism,
economic populism into your movement so you can energize voters,
right? People are upset with the status quo. Even if that's a
stupid belief to be upset with the status quo, even if that's
foundationally stupid.
Do you think you should be publicly supporting anybody who is
pushing away from the status quo? Oh, sorry, publishing or publicly
resisting anybody who's pushing away from the status quo. Like,
even if it's a stupid position, I don't know if you should publicly
resist anybody saying these things. It doesn't necessarily make
sense to me. It sort of makes you look like the the party of
status quo, the party of um institutional dominance. Like, as
much as I do believe in institutions, I think there's some concerning
level of There's There's something concerning there that everybody's
saying everything is right now and you're going, "Whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. We need the exact same thing right
now. We need the exact same thing."
That That to me, it feels like there's a mismatch between what
the voter where the voters are at and where the party is >> And
then now just talking more generally about what the Democrats'
position should be, but I think a lot of incumbents need to go.
I think a lot of Democrats One of the reasons, even though I
I know that IRI discounts a lot of polling and stuff, but one
of the reasons I think the Democrats are souring on their own
party is because of some of these old like old guard figures
that have no reason that they don't, you know, believe in. >> Wasn't
the Wasn't the big problem with 2016 that people felt like the
DNC was showing a bias? Like, I I [laughter] don't know if like
that >> Well, well, I'm just asking I thought you said
that it's the DNC policy to support incumbents. And that's a
bias in favor of incumbents. >> Right, but but it seems
like you're you're proposing a a new system where they would,
you know, potentially support primary challenges, which means
>> Well, I'm just I'm just questioning whether or not if
it is a policy to support incumbents as a matter of course, what's
what's the wisdom of that >> Well, I think strategically
it makes sense cuz incumbents have such an advantage. Um but
but again, I I you this would be introducing a new kind of a
new kind of bias into the DNC, which basically runs counter to
the the criticism from 2016. So, I I don't know. I like is it
the right decision? I don't >> It might be statistically
right. I know it caused Nancy Pelosi to support that like, you
know, pro-life Democrat in Texas for that one house seat, which
was I think it was just an atrocious decision. So, I I don't
think there should just be this hardline support the incumbent.
It should be support like the candidate who wins the primary,
right? Um like if you're like putting your >> By the way,
if they do have a national policy to support the incumbent,
what Oh, man.
Then isn't a lot of the rhetoric towards the lefties by Hutch
like wrong? Like, "Oh, just, you know, guys, just win the primaries."
It's like, "Well, no, there's an institutional bias. They literally
are institutionally
set up to support the candidates." There's a bias there you're
not referencing or not like winking at or or acknowledging when
you say, "Oh, well, just support the
Right? Like, "Oh, but the party is going to support the incumbent,
who's obviously in most cases not going to be a progressive."
>> toe on the scale of those primaries. Like, shouldn't
the Democratic voters get to decide which Democrat's the best
one? And once that's the case, your job is to beat Republicans,
not to pick like which Democrat is the one that you like more?
I don't know. I don't like that idea, and I don't like the idea
of funding from the Democratic Party going to like kind of affecting
primaries in that way, but I I'd have to look and see like what
the actual outcomes are in the majority. That was the one time
where I really focused on that other than the Bernie-Hillary
stuff, so. >> I And if I was going to support him Oh, go
on. >> A competition is good. I I don't think the Democratic
Party should stand in the way of people being challenged. You
should have to fight for your job every time. It just makes you
stronger.
>> 100% I agree. Well, one last thing I just wanted to
add is like when I met Ken Martin uh in San Francisco, and he
was doing this thing that was supposedly my understanding was
I'm out I'm reaching out to creators because we just lost the
election, and we want to figure out how we can do what Hutchin
and I and all of you guys are talking about, which is, "Hey,
we need some cool like young voices to like get their finger
on the pulse of where the country is cuz our media strategy doesn't
work." And he was talking about like, "We fired all the media
strategists in 2024." But he did not, I don't think, ask a single
question of any of the people there about how to
>> He was just preaching? Well,
I need to talk to all of the influencers who have their finger
on the pulse. Now, listen to me tell you what you should be telling
people. >> It was all him reassuring us. Like, by the way,
and this is what we're doing right. As if to like make us his
cheerleaders. And I'm like, well, this is not what you should
be doing. Contrasted to Gavin Newsom met with some people at
TwitchCon, and he was asking really good questions. Like, what
kind of audiences do you have? How do these messages disseminate?
What do What are they looking for? What are people in your audience
like What are the problems that they're most focused on? Can
did none of that. And that did not inspire me with confidence.
So, as to whether or not he should step down, I've seen time
and time again, maybe he's fundraising well, but he's just making
poor decisions that I don't think are going to be putting the
money in the right spot. And I would rather someone who, you
know, inspires me with confidence. But, if the people that he
is giving the money to are inspired by this, and they're like,
"Hey, you're doing a good job. You're helping my race out." then
that's really the most important metric. And you know, I'm just
an influencer, so I can't speak to whether or not he should step
down. It's just what I'm
I want to say one one other thing, which is um Well, if you take
the view,
don't necessarily think it's just the people who he's funding.
I think there would be something with the donors. You do need
donors who are confident in the Democratic Party, who are willing
to donate money. You need to. You You need that, okay? That's
the way this works, right? That is You have to be willing to
court money. I understand that it would be nice to get money
out of politics, at least to some some far more significant degree
than has been done so far. But, in the current environment, you
do have to court these people, and his inability to do that,
his inability to do that, is a problem.
And I do believe that actually the problem is mostly with him,
based on the Matt Yglesias article we read on stream before.
It is like him having personal issues with donors. It's them
not liking him as a personality, as a person.
That is not good for a DNC chair, whose primary job is really
about raising
>> That Jon Favreau did something like horrible in that
exchange with Ken Martin. Um I just think that and if Or if Ken
Martin thought it was a good idea to go in there antagonistically,
as he did in my view he did. Um not to say that Jon Favreau wasn't
like obviously going down a strict line of questioning there.
I I I just don't think that you're in tune in with the Democratic
base. My view of it which is most people want to see more fight.
Most people want to see a closer connection to the the voting
members. And I just don't have the confidence um that he is doing
that right now and that he has the um you know, self-reflection
perhaps to to make those changes unless it's in his direct interest
or when it gets like out of hand. And we're we need to be like
ruthless. And part of being ruthless means if it is appropriate
at the time to make a change in leadership. And like let's not
just rest on our laurels. Uh we learned that lesson or I thought
we learned that lesson from Biden. Um so, you know, that's just
something I want to carry forward in all walks of Democratic
leadership. >> Well, I I I just I feel like Pod Save America
and it it sounds like whatever show McMorrow went on, like they're
they're not trying to help it in my opinion. It it may seem like
it and if you ask them they'll tell you, "I'm just trying to
help." But the way they frame their questions and the the way
they interrogate these people just makes
>> Dude, IRI was like completely moronic when he reviewed
this stuff. When he talked about the Ken Martin interview, like
Ken Martin directly lied to Jon Favreau. That is That is literally
Jon
pressing Ken Martin for lying to him
It's not It's not about the Dems at that point. It is the DNC
chair went on the the Pod Save podcast and said, "We're releasing
this and oh, there's a bunch of other stuff, too. Oh."
He He kept talking about how like we have lessons and all of
this as well, right? Oh guys, we've learned a bunch of lessons
here. Oh, we might need to watch a little bit of that Jon Favreau.
I've watched it personally, but I have not watched it on stream
yet. The the actual like follow-up interview. We watched a decent
amount of it with IRI as well.
Oh no, I've watched a decent amount of it through IRI. Okay,
but like
IRI was getting really mad at them for bagging on Ken Martin.
It's like, "Dude, Ken Martin directly lied. What lessons are
you pushing out? What lessons did you learn from the report that
you're pushing out when you then publish the report and show
actually this was done incompetently and you say you don't about
any of the results.
That's nuts.
Like you just lied directly to his face. Of course he could be
pissed about it. >> that they're not even trying to figure
anything out because they can't point to anything positive. It's
all negative and they they seem just completely convinced that
something needs to change as we win by double digits in and I
just I don't get that vibe Pisco that these guys are actually
trying to help.
Well, I don't think they're on the right or mega or fake you
know Democrats but why are they so angry? Why are they so convinced
they're right and there's no love or anything no support in any
way. I'm not first thing I'll take on is like this notion of
their antagonism. Aren't they vindicated by Ken Martin's response?
I mean Ken Martin came out and said I'm sorry it was the wrong
move uh with respect to the report. Doesn't that mean that Jon
Favreau even Ken Martin acknowledges was correct in the criticism
of the reports? >> He was but but we could have convinced
Ken Martin to release the report in a much different way. You
know what I mean? Like if Ken Martin came on this show we could
raise the same concerns in the way they did in a completely different
way because we're doing it from a place of hey we want to And
I don't get that vibe from them. I just get they just want to
antagonize. Yes, but Ken Martin went with the approach that Pod
Save to do the interview on that issue and so it's not
>> Ken Martin went explicit Oh, Pisco. Pisco definitely
watched my video on this. Pisco watched me like
Oh, I know he did. I hate to you know suck myself off but Pisco
absolutely
watched the exact points I made about
obviously Ken Martin went into this interview knowing that it
was going to be hostile. He explicitly wanted to argue with somebody
about whether or not the report should be released and then he
lied to try to make his point. Obviously, come on man. >> It
cannot be I think reasonably construed as an ambush. If uh Martin
is seeking out an interview with Pod Save America on this issue
and he knows it's going to come up. He knows it's about to critique.
In fact, he goes up to Favreau specifically because he's mad
at the critique. Then in no sense can I say that this is an attempt
by Pod Save to try to like with Ken Martin.
>> If you watch that interview, the counter arguments that
Ken Martin was giving were not really addressing what Jon Favreau
was saying. Jon Favreau had a criticism and Ken Martin had this
kind of like rehearsed like, "Well, actually there's no smoking
gun." to a question that didn't really suggest that there was
because he was so used and knew these criticisms were going to
come up that he was already kind of getting ahead of things that
John wasn't even asking yet. So, it's not as if he like walked
in blind and got ambushed. He was very aware that this was like
I want to fix the off >> Wait, there's no way Slotkin asked
for the turning point or the breaking points
There's no way that Slotkin asked for that breaking points interview
and then went on and was shocked that Cristobal was mad about
Gaza. That's not possible. There's no way.
There's no way they're they're framing this as an ambush the
whole time.
And it's just very clear that
like what was going to happen. It's It's obvious to anybody.
The comms person didn't debrief her um >> Oh, boy. >> much
of it I think he was like answering questions that weren't being
asked because he was so ready for this to be like a Gaza, Gaza,
Gaza sort of thing, right? So, I I I'm not sure this is like
a oh, we're being so unfair. If you look at the McMorrow interview,
the questions they ask are, "Hey, like we like, you know, XYZ
policy, but in general like this healthcare thing you just said,
we fundamentally disagree with. You are implying that she watches
this back and says it's a joke, but she implied that if you have
government in charge of healthcare and then Donald Trump gets
in office, it will be bad. Therefore, the government shouldn't
be in charge of that social program." which is an absurd thing
to say. That's not how anyone views social programs. Like, "Oh,
we couldn't have them because if a Republican gets in office,
they'll be run poorly." Um so, they confronted her on that cuz
it's like, "Hey, this is a fundamental disagreement from what
would have otherwise appeared to be two aligned Democrats." And
I don't think this is just like I just want to be antagonistic.
It's like, "Hey, this this is disqualifying for someone that
I would vote for in a primary over the person that's not going
to say cut social programs." >> But But there you go, Slotkin,
you nailed it. They're always looking for disqualifying thing.
It's like the
That would piss me off so much. I go in I construct this like
argument this well-thought-out argument to make deliver my point
and then somebody just totally thought terminates on the word
disqualify and just goes, "They're always talking about disqualifying
somebody. It's all about purity testing. Don't you guys see that
this is always about a purity test and really not about Bro,
could you answer the ques I just I just worked so hard. I had
to go look stuff up. I had to read articles. I had to talk to
people. I bounced this argument off a couple people. And then
you just thought terminated on one word and don't respond materially
to anything I say.
Do you understand how frustrating that
That's incredibly frustrating when somebody does that to you,
right? I know I do that to people sometimes. I'm sure it happens
all the time. But when you're the person who's like laying out
a very meticulous argument and someone does that to you, it
>> for these guys is just to fire and get rid of things.
They they never want to work with what's right in front of them
in any way. It's always like this you got to go or you got to
get fired. It's like that's not how life works, you know? It's
like we're a family. You you don't just fire your family. You
work with them. >> It's just it's a new kind of incarnation
of Bernie or Bust. It's like Saagar or >> Dude, oh do not
do not talk about Saagar, you bald coward.
Keep Abdul El-Sayed's name out your god damn mouth, Hutch. Holy
I You know what? Have they talked about the Abdul El-Sayed thing?
I hope Hutch gets pressed on that cuz his >> conversation
it's like you're >> His takes on El-Sayed were shameful.
Totally shameful, man.
You are out of your god damn mind.
Okay.
All right. I need to I need to remain calm. I need to remain
calm. >> viewing a US Senate Senate candidate who will
be a part of so many consequential votes that address dozens
of like consequential issues in this country and it's an hour-long
interview and you spend 15 minutes pressing her on Medicare for
All, a policy that
>> Ryan Girdy in the chat. I think Bad and the Todd Save
Guys are different. Pod Save Gurley Martin is part of Insider
Dem Establishment Beef.
Oh, it's like the people who actually pay attention to politics
seem to all
I just think it's funny that I I put these ideas out. I know
they're correct. I know I'm saying the right thing. I had a whole
thing dude, I actually worked to go and find all the stuff cuz
I knew I knew I had a point here.
Like one of the only political stories I've really followed from
the start
in the past like year or so. And it's just cool seeing all the
people who actually know anything about politics, all the people
who actually put any work into politics
all agree with my exact take on it. It's so nice. It just feels
good, right? When I've been doing a bunch of drama stuff and
you come back to the politics stuff and everybody who pays any
attention just totally agrees. You love to see it. You love to
see it. >> to passing in the Congress. It's not going to
pass in the next Congress or the one after that probably. Probably
not the one after that either. Um and then the rest of the 45
minutes is on Gaza. And it's like, okay, that's we can have a
conversation about Gaza and foreign policy, that's fine. But
I just feel like to IRI's point, they're not there with any kind
of curiosity.
It is for them a broader campaign, a broader agenda of like wiping
out the Democratic Party of everyone that is not in their particular
tent. And it's extremely
hostile and antagonistic and you know, it's a little uncomfortable
to be in a coalition with these people. I don't think Emma's
as bad as other lefties. I mean, she was pushing for >> I
mean, I'm sure some people who believe there's a genocide happening
in Gaza, they probably feel a little uncomfortable being with
people who aid and abet a genocide, right? I would say the discomfort
goes bi-directionally, right? It probably goes both ways. Those
people are probably very, very, very uncomfortable sharing a
party with people who are like, "No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, we should actually send a bunch of arms to Israel still."
Like, actually, you seem kind of monstrous. You seem kind of
like evil,
That That might be a lot of people's
It's not shocking that they want to make an issue out of it.
This is like saying, you know, the the people who who talk about
abortion, who who are pro-life, it's like being shocked when
they're upset
that you are pro-abortion.
Like, no, they they think like maybe not to the extent of like,
you know, another human being, but they think a life's being
ended, right? Of course they're
If you can't even enter the conversation with some understanding
of their like moral framework, then you'll never reach any understanding
with them whatsoever. The idea that you just can't fathom them
being upset about this thing, that's bizarre to me. >> For
people to vote for Kamala, you know, I don't I wouldn't put her
on the same tier as like Hasan or anything like that, but Yeah,
but she's a well-known division because of the Democratic
Yeah, but come on, he's got 45 minutes on Gaza. 45 minutes? >> Oh,
I mean, I don't know I haven't seen the interview. 45 minutes
on Gaza seems like way too much for an interview with a Senate
candidate. Um, so I mean, yeah, if if it's 45 minutes there,
I'm going to be honest, I haven't seen it. I'm just responding
to what you're saying. But on the on the point about Medicare
for All versus uh public option versus increasing Affordable
Care Act and all that stuff, these are not like some out there
divisions in the Democratic Party. This was the basis of the
2020 campaign, Sanders against uh Joe Biden. It's one of the
biggest, you know, I I I guess policy ideological disagreements
between those two. And I think if if you're you can't be surprised
by that. If you're a Democratic candidate running a Democratic
primary, and this is one of the big divisions in the Democratic
sort of ideological camp, you got to be ready for that and just
knock it out of the park. And yeah, >> I think he did fine
for the record. He >> I think she did fine. I don't think
that's a problem. 45 minutes on Gaza, I mean, that seems like
too much, but it just to be aware, like, this is also now a crystallizing
moment for the Democratic Party, where we are Israel skeptic.
We don't want and I'm just speaking now for the majority of the
Democratic Party, we don't want to give military or economic
aid to Israel based on what their conduct is in the Middle East,
to say nothing of the Iran war. And that just is a position we
want to see reflected in the Democratic Senate. I want to see
that position reflected in the in the Democratic Senate. Now,
do I want 45 minutes? No, but uh I do think it's fair to ask
those questions. >> Well, you said it's she's not Hasan,
right? And I agree. And like, what's the fundamental difference
there? The difference is I fully support people rallying and
criticizing and getting attacked from the left in primaries because
you want to push the people that you are going to be represented
by to be more aligned with you. I think this is the time to do
it. To go, "Hey, there's two Democrats in this primary. >> This
is literally when they're doing when they're talking about Planer
and
like that was that was their argument, right? Well, Well, primary
season. During the primaries, we're allowed to do this.
But apparently not on anybody I don't Dude, I don't know. I've
given up on trying to really make it consistent in any way. >> Let's
talk to the one who might have a better chance of winning and
see if we can move the needle a little bit. >> That's not
what they're doing, though. That's not what they're doing. Come
on. >> I don't What do you mean? If you're challenging
her things that aren't as left as you and saying like I think
you need to change on that, that's exactly the time to do it.
What's wrong with >> They're They're side or bust. It's
not like, well, I could warm up to her. >> No, but you
know the side You know that's like Emma is not side or bust.
She's not
you know, whatever primary person or bust, Bernie or bust. She's
like, "Hey, go vote for Kamala. Kamala needs to win." Right?
That The majority of our people are not dead-enders. So, if you
were talking We You and I have the same smoke for Hasan, which
is if you're going to criticize, criticize, criticize, and then
not even help when it comes to the general, all you've done is
hurt, right? Because you didn't get what you wanted, and now
you're going to sabotage our chances. That's what >> you're
subpoenaed. >> Yeah. Now we'll get to that. We'll get to
that. I mean, here I guess maybe most more sense to some of these
supers like as they're relevant. They say promoting better, you
know, and this is opinionated, primary candidates and demanding
better party conduct so Dems win more if that was the case. Again,
this is making assumptions, is helping the Democratic Party.
I mean, it depends on who you're promoting and why. But it's
the it's the time [laughter] to do it, right? It's during the
primary. You're supposed to say, "Hey, I would If you're going
to win >> Like Hudge goes into these conversations, and
he's foundationally just thinking if you're like a lefty candidate,
you're the worst candidate automatically. That's why he does
this thing. By the way, he can't not be this person, right? He
can't not be this like overconfident, arrogant
>> more if that was the case. Again, this is making assumptions,
is helping the Democratic Party. I mean, it depends on who you're
promoting and why. But it's the it's the time >> Like he
he just like scoffs at people all the time. He's just scoffing,
treating them like they're dumb.
And realistically, I've no problem with that if that's the dynamic.
But then when other people do this to him, when other people
do this exact same behavior back to him, he loses his mind.
He's like a total whiny about it.
Like whatever. If you're If you're going to let it go with everybody
else, that's fine, okay? You can do your scoffs. And then when
somebody scoffs back at you,
Don't get Don't get weird about it. But he totally
seems to think that he should be protected. He should be treated
nicely, and he fails to do that with his friends so often. It's
so obvious, and I get so irritated watching it. >> Well,
right? It's during the primary. You're supposed to say, "Hey,
I would If you're going to win I don't When's the When When are
we allowed to criticize the >> Because that person's super
chat is talking about 2028. So, the time to think about 2028
is after these midterms, not before. That's what >> The
time to criticize is is like not right after the election. We
need to unite cuz we need to fundraise, and it's not right before
the midterms cuz we need to unite cuz we need to win the midterms.
And then after the midterms, like maybe there's a little bit
of time to criticize, but then it's on to 2028. We're You know,
by the time we're 3 months out from the midterms, we are on to
2028. Why would you be criticizing going into 2028, guys? It's
They will always find a reason to make the same argument. So,
you kind of just have to like move it away, right? Just like
ignore it entirely. Oh, this is not the time. Well, if it's not
the time now, it'll never be the time. I Anytime somebody argues
this is not the time, you could all If they've ever argued that
before, okay? Or if they argue that with any frequency whatsoever,
just throw it out. If it's like there's times where you can argue
that, right?
I don't know why I went here. If somebody is like injured, somebody
gets their arm cut off in an industrial accident, and then you
argue with the medic about like what's for lunch or what why
it's like bad to have certain cafeteria items on the menu. It's
like, "DUDE, NOW'S NOT THE TIME."
RIGHT? The medic's got to go. But for this, it's just for the
DNC, it's never the time. For the Democrats, it's never the time.
When will be the time? >> Driving me nuts is that all these
people are like concern trolling about 2028, but we don't even
see the midterm results yet. They're not They're not trying to
push McMorrow left. They're drawing like the battle lines that
have been drawn, you know? And And as far as like I'm glad that
Emma tells her audience that, you know, the the harm reduction
principle is is valid, and they should support Kamala and but
for example like on the off-cycle election last November, you
know, I watched a bit of their live coverage and you know, obviously
they were elated over Mondaire as they should have been. That
was a really big win.
but they were actively like downplaying they were so salty about
Mikie Sherrill and Abigail Spanberger's Abigail Spanberger's
margins. They were they were legitimately pissed off that people
were talking about how crazy those margins were and they they
thought that it was like some plot to like under undermine this,
you know, the real winner of that night which was Mondaire. So,
you know, like they're on the team but you know, they're not
like the best people to have on the team cuz when it's not an
election year, they're constantly using their platforms to accuse
people like McMurrow who is, you know, somewhere on the spectrum
between like center-left and progressive. She's like decently
progressive and if you didn't get Medicare
>> Hold on. Hold on.
Hold on.
If it's not an election year they're using their platforms. I
thought you said oh listen, they can have differences of opinion
but when it comes to election time they've got to fall in Have
we just moved the goalposts again?
Has Huch realized that like probably a bunch of the people I
was criticizing actually did use their platforms to support Kamala
Harris and actually probably did support the Democratic candidate
and have done so in most elections and so now he realizes that
criticism was stupid.
And so now he's falling back to a totally different criticism
which is like well, actually if if off years if in off years
they still criticize then that's bad too. It's like okay, so
your position is all criticism of the Democratic Party is immoral.
I know that's not your position but that's what you're essentially
putting out here. >> If we had a public option it would
still be awesome and it would drive costs down and it would expand
coverage to so many people and so to them I just don't like the
all or nothing mentality. I don't think it's helpful. >> It's
not all or nothing, right? We both agree that these people specifically
are not all or nothing people. They're hey, we didn't get what
we want and this is why we've got to support those people and
you can be salty that you didn't get what you want. Like, you
know, I could be mad Bernie didn't win in 2020 and still say,
"And here's where we're all going to go out and campaign for
Joe Biden cuz this is such a better option." That's what I'm
going to do
>> Have the goal post moved for Hutch
Dude, have they really moved again? There's no way, right? There's
no way these goal posts have moved another
>> That's what I do. That's not all or nothing. That's
I criticized them when I had the chance. I wanted this. I didn't
get it. I'm salty about it. And you know what? I'm still going
to help you win. And if they're in the tent, they're in the tent,
right? And that's those are That's Emma. Okay, I don't know about
Bernie Sanders. I don't know enough about him, but like >> My
guy. >> My guy. >> Well, these are not just These
are not just policy disagreements though. Um I would like to
get back at like as a party to get back to a place where we can
have policy disagreements and it doesn't mean that you're, you
know, like if if you don't meet their purity test, they designate
you as like a pro-Israel, pro-genocide, pro-corporation
shill. And you know, everybody else is like in their
>> Yep. Okay. If you don't meet their purity test, on
I'm sorry, do they represent people who are not pro-Israel as
pro-Israel?
I I don't like
>> In their tent. >> But really we're talking about
like 95% of the party. That's what I don't like. Like it's it's
not about like just policy disagreements. Does that make >> 95%
of the party is with who?
>> I'm saying 95% of the party would not pass their purity
test. >> Oh, of the >> Like actual actual actual
elected >> Here's the way to test it, Hutch. If
>> Hutch has basically just hit on the true problem with
the Democratic Party.
A massive majority of the Democratic Party supports like basically
not giving aid to Israel anymore, possibly even weapons embargoes
against Israel, okay?
But Hutch just hit it perfectly that a lot of the elected representatives
somehow
don't give a [__] about what their constituents think
and have decided to continuously support Israel
If they're not going to represent their voters on this issue
at all, what the [__] are we even doing here? Primary
Obviously, there is no reason this is actually a fundamental
problem that is going to [__] you over in elections,
Obviously, it will. Right? If you have a like a wedge issue that
Okay, let's say let's say foreign policy is not or even Israel's
not high up on people's list. But if you work against the entire
constituency on that one issue, like right? Like let's say people
think um What if women's reproductive rights were not high on
the list? And so the whole party, despite being the party that
is that all the constituents are pro-choice, they start going
pro-life.
But it doesn't like it it's not high up in the decision matrix,
so it doesn't like immediately cost them votes. Why would you
just operate against 95% of your party? Like as a broadly like
it Sorry. Uh why as 95% of the elected representatives would
you go against 80% of your constituents?
That doesn't make any sense to me. Some breakaways in terms of
red states or purple states might make sense.
But how does the broad-based the majority of Democrats how do
they consistently pull away from their constituency on this one
issue? >> Why do these lefty channels like Pod Save America
or whatever Majority Report
>> This lefty channel This lefty channel like Pod Save
America and Majority Pod Save America and Majority Dude, somebody
get Emma Vigeland on the line and show her that clip right there.
These Pod Save America and and the Majority Report are equivalently
or essentially equivalent. Dude, Emma Vigeland would lose her
She would lose her mind, man.
That would be so funny to watch Emma Vigeland react to that.
>> Ask the Why do these lefty channels like Pod Save America
or whatever Majority
>> THAT'S AWESOME. THAT'S AWESOME. We love that. We love
that for Pisco. Okay.
God help me. Lord save me. Lord protect me from Lord forgive
ME FOR WHAT I MUST DO.
>> THEY ASSUME THAT THESE people are like evil almost.
That they they say there's there's like no charity at all that
they're coming from a good place and that they just have a different
approach to things and and they're even for people within our
own party. It's it's mind-blowing. I could talk to the most leftist
socialist person ever and it wouldn't be a fistfight because
I think they're coming from a good place. I disagree with them
but I I I'm not going to attack them like they're a monster,
you know. >> Pod Save can't be considered one of those
lefty shows. They're like in favor of promoting Act Blue and
like and they were all in on Kamala Harris to win the election.
>> Thank you only well not only same person seems like
Soy Pills towing the same line today to as well. So thank you.
Pisco, thank you for saying the thing that is obvious. >> 100%
trying to raise money and and get us across the finishing line.
They're Obama bros. Are they really like lefty types uh that
they're not quite like they're not quite like Hasan but I think
that they've definitely positioned themselves to be more aligned
with like that space for
>> They positioned themselves to reap rewards from being
kind to those people.
They are not at all what what concessions have they given?
What concessions have they given to the to Hasan or that coalition?
Hutch or IRI, please tell me. What concessions have the Pod Save
America guys given to Hasan?
You know what they did? They did the intelligent thing, the thing
you're incapable of and they went hey Hasan, why don't you come
on and just hang out cuz we want to be your friend." And Hasan
can come on and he can go, "I think it'd be really cool if we
did Medicare for All." And they go, "Like, that's really cool,
man. What's your workout plan? Oh, that's cool. Awesome. Awesome.
Well, thanks for coming on and come back another time.
We love you, man. Have a good one. Right? That's what they do.
That's That's literally all they do. >> Like when Like
when am I >> It's not that hard. >> Whenever you
want. >> criticize, it's just how you're doing it that
I have a problem with. Not you personally, but in general. I
have a problem with how these people, the Hasans of the world,
are criticizing the Democratic Party. It doesn't feel genuine.
It feels that they have an agenda as Hutch was saying. >> Would
you agree? >> Hold on. Wait. Wait. Wait. >> I Maybe
I'm going to start strive. Hutch, when you repost the El Saied
is lying about his doctor credentials, is this the right way
to CRITICIZE
>> LET'S GO. LET'S GO.
I love this Abdul El Saied guy, okay? If you guys aren't If you
guys haven't been here, I love to this guy's background. This
guy is like elite human capital. This guy has been awesome everywhere
he's ever gone. And the people who have been denigrating him
are this
Call of Duty player and a uh failed a music school dropout who
is a carpet cleaner. Those are the people who are judging the
Rhodes Scholar who obtained a PhD and MD in like what? Six Six
years? Seven years?
This guy This guy went crazy.
This guy is elite. This guy is By the way, while being the captain
of the Oxford lacrosse
One of the captains of the Oxford lacrosse team while he went
to Oxford to
this This dude is elite human capital. How dare you criticize
this man who has titanic discipline, who is who is an absolute
titan, okay? How dare you? How dare you criticize this man and
say maybe he's not Maybe I'm calling himself a physician is a
little too much. It's
It's not.
>> as a candidate when it has nothing to do with his policy,
but it's a character attack on whether or not he's been misleading
the public.
thing to do with his policy, but [clears throat] it's a character
on whether or not he's been misleading the public.
>> I don't even know if I >> Is your Is your agenda
that you don't like his policies? >> I don't even I don't
even know if I I don't even know what what Why are you asking
me about that? Why are you asking me about that? >> And
so you're going on about the doctor thing or is it like this
person's untrustworthy? Like to me, this would be far beyond
what they did to McMorrow and it actually might be a legitimate
criticism, right? It's like hold on, if this guy's lying to people,
this is not a legitimate person we should be trusting. However,
I think that to say that that's allowed and what you know, having
McMorrow on and asking her questions about the things she said
is an unacceptable way. >> If you want to really nail someone
>> I think the way we're posing the story is worse. >> No,
let's do it. Let's do it one for one. Let's say you invited El
Sayed and you were grilling him on the doctor thing. Would you
say it's unacceptable?
>> No, I don't think so at all.
At all. At >> So, why would that be different than the
Israel thing? Why is that any different than the Israel issue?
What? >> Oh, but there's a difference
>> Did it turn out to be he wasn't misleading at all and
he proved it? Well, it's that basically people think if you're
not a practicing physician, you shouldn't say you're a physician.
But I don't believe that's a protected term in Michigan.
Right? In New York, he might have given an interview where he
called himself a
and it is a protected term and he shouldn't have done that, but
it's like one infraction in New York. He's not in New York, he
operates in Michigan, right? And it's like a ticky-tack rule.
He got his MD, he did do rounds as like a med student and he
decided not to go into medicine like as a field. He was going
to try to be a surgeon. And he decided not to do a residency,
like a surgical residency. He decided to actually go into public
policy instead, right? Epidemiology and public policy. And he
did a bunch of research papers, he taught for a little bit, and
then he went into actual public policy to run as a politician.
He decided that the best way to use his MD, his knowledge of
the human body, of how you run a met like any medical operation,
he decided to use these things to inform his healthcare policy
and run as a politician because he thought that was the scale
at which he could affect the greatest change, the greatest positive
change in the world. And so he talks about healing the system,
healing America. And he uses these terms and allegories toward
like allegories from medicine.
And they basically freak the [__] out and said, "You're
not really a doctor or physician. Why are you doing this?" It's
like, "Well, he's got an MD, and he's been very transparent about
his entire path through his entire career."
And this is not even the first time this attack has been attempted.
It's just sad to me that this guy who is again, like totally
like This guy has worked so hard to get to where he is as young
as he is in his life. This is a guy you want leading people.
This is a guy you want in a position of authority. This is a
guy you want making decisions. This is a fantastic human being
who by all accounts is great at every single thing he's ever
attempted. Why wouldn't you want this guy in politics? Why are
you trying to chase this guy out of
You should be going, "Thank you. Thank you, LORD JESUS, FOR PROVIDING
this man to me who can lead my countrymen, who can be a great
example of American ingenuity, of American like drive, and just
American greatness overall."
Why the [__] would you ever question this guy on,
"Oh, well, he called himself a physician."
Dude, it's so insane to me. The Blaze is crazy? Well, it should
be though. It should be.
Why the [__] Dude, Kash Patel is like a failed middling
prosecutor.
And they put him in government. Why not put somebody who's elite,
who's been great at everything they've ever done in
Why would you chase this guy out? Why would you smear this guy?